grateful always to allow god for
allowing me to come out here so i'm just
grateful
a lot of people have questions but yeah
i am taking part in ramadan with a lot
of my brothers and sisters
my muslim brothers sisters and it's been
an adjustment
that's really what i can say just being
committed
to my service to god allah and then
continuing on
with whatever i'm guided with so you
know just happy to
to be part of my my community and doing
the right things
so fasting is definitely part of it
obviously if you know anything about the
muslim
community um but yeah i'm just just
really
blessed and grateful to to be taken
apart
and then kyrie he he didn't really do do
great at his time in boston
but now it seems like he's muslim so
it's like all right fine you know i
gotta like kyrie
and now stephen jackson all right good i
like stephen jackson you know my
my love of uh my muslims is stronger
than my love of my sports teams
tell me do you know this uh this other
basketball prayer
uh player irving kyrie irving
yeah that's who i was just mentioning
yeah he used to be okay so that's the
guy you're mentioning that's the guy
he's not he so he accepted islam because
i was i didn't know who he was before
but then someone was telling me he was
quoting you know allah god and he was
tweeting some things like that so that's
the one that's the guy you're talking
about
that's the guy i'm talking about and you
know we we i have a good opinion
inshallah you know he's just
he's in his uh tweets lately he's been
saying us
[Music]
and you know calling people brothers so
um
you know there's a there's a lot of uh
within the african-american community
whether it's within the
amongst rappers or basketball players
there's a strong pull towards islam
and a lot of people you know kind of in
that gray zone we hope
they fall into the white zone inshallah
but um
it's uh you know it's really cool to see
and there's a lot of basketball players
like that it's not just kyrie it's like
jaylen brown
um carmelo anthony and we could go on
and on uh even
i think i've heard kevin durant like who
knows right but there's just a lot of
names out there shaq's a famous one of
course
shaquille o'neal huh yeah you hear him
saying salaam alaikum
you know what that that's the you at a
young age of 16
courageous brave you know just kind of
uh comparing it to
many of these famous people out there
you know the basketball players
didn't he get some also some heat like
people start to like they love him
basketball player but as soon as you try
to mention islam or whatnot then it's
like oh
yeah they try to push you under a rock
or something have you noticed that
yeah yeah you know that's why it's so
important that muslims be
cool basically right i mean like it's
certainly when muhammad ali changed his
name like he became muslim changed his
name from cassius clay muhammad ali
you had people saying oh i'm not even
you know what's his name that box is
like i'm not even going to call him
muhammad his his christian name is
cassius that's when we call him and
you know muhammad ali whooped him right
and he just came what what's my name
he was like say my name say my name
sometimes
you got to be you got to have that kind
of bravado a little bit
um to just let people know like no i'm a
muslim i'm proud to be muslim
there's no shame in it um nothing to
apologize for you know
but then if you back it up with your
game like hakeem elijah won and win
you know back-to-back championships like
what are people going to say